Josh give us a few examples of how this
would work well basically if you have a
big bill moving or maybe a big defense
contractor if you can get that
information early enough that can have a
big effect on markets and on companies
that can give you an advantage as an
investor if you can get that information
before the rest of the market and then
there are other cases that shade in the
more of a gray legal area we learned
last week for instance that one of these
political intelligence firms found out
about the internal workings of a Fed
meeting in 2012 where Chairman Bernanke
was thinking about a third round of
quantitative easing so obviously if
that's something you can find out about
early you can act on it unfortunately
that's not legal and so there is now an
ongoing criminal investigation into the
source of that league well yeah how do
these political intelligence companies
get their information well it's a good
question oftentimes they hire former
White House officials former
congressional staffers when i was doing
reporting for this piece calling around
to different people I've been told do
this work different firms a lot of them
were pumping me for information
sometimes they'll call up a reporter
after a story and say you know can you
tell me more about this so really the
answer is you get the information from
anywhere you can and try and find
something that is actionable and
tradable that you have that other people
don't have that can provide an investing
advantage well to politicians offices
actually provide information and do they
have an incident you again this this is
this is very gray area yes there in the
end they're in the habit of providing
information to reporters to lobbyists
who work on bills and so part of what
these firms do is try and get in on some
of these phone calls find out about
these briefings and it's it's tough
because the lines aren't is clearly
delineated as one might expect and there
has been pushed back from some major
members of Congress to try and regulate
this industry most recently through the
2012 stock act and Wall Street was
actually able to step in and prevent the
intelligence industry from being
regulated so we know that it's a big
industry but nobody has a clear idea of
exactly how big or how far-reaching it
is but hang on if reporters know it's
arguably publican information right I'm
if reporters can find out then anybody
can find out no offense to us obviously
well I'll try I'll try not to take
offense with that that's certainly what
I try and do the issue is really are
they getting material nonpublic
information even beyond what reporters
are getting and there's certainly some
examples of cases where they are there
was a famous case that's also part of
the Securities Exchange investigation
where news of a Medicare rate hike
leaked a day before the announcement you
saw a bunch of the big insurers move
higher I don't know any reporter that
had that story but obviously a few big
investors and hedge funds have been
tipped off made a lot of money it's not
clear again whether that was legal but
it just shows you that there is
information that the press can't get
that sometimes these political
intelligence folks are able to get make
a lot of money from yeah is there any
evidence that politicians are actually
getting kickbacks from these political
intelligence companies by way of
campaign contributions well they
certainly get contributions in one of
the methods that these firms told me
they use is oftentimes they will be big
donors to important politicians they
wouldn't call it anything as explicitly
as a kickback for information but by
virtue of being an important donor often
they are able to get a senator on the
phone get a congressman on the phone be
able to have sort of a private briefing
or even to suggest that the congressman
take x y&z action that could potentially
help some of the firms that they're
invested in so again I know I keep going
back to this term it's a very gray area
and it's a very profitable one if you're
able to do this kind of work and sort of
keep under the noses of regulators and
congressmen